hey leute was glaubt jetzt willkommen
beim neuen video
gestern kam mir meinen 300.000
abonnenten special und das ist
eigentlich auch so mit der auslöser
warum ich dieses video jetzt hier auf
nehme ich muss einfach mal drüber reden
weil es wirklich so eine sache
die liegt nicht in letzter zeit so
aufrichtig check das nicht so okay wir
fangen an und ihr könnt ihr dann eure
meinung dazu in die kommentare schreiben
ich denke ihr könnt mich verstehen wenn
ihr mich nicht verstehen könnt dann
könnt ihr mich nicht verstehen was ich
nicht verstehen abstand also wie gesagt
gestern kam ein 300.000 abonnenten
special wenn es noch nicht gesehen habe
ist noch mal ganz oben in der video
beschreibung verlinkt klick drauf schaut
doch mal an und ich bin auch ehrlich
gesagt total zufrieden damit wie das
angekommen ist ich meine das hat jetzt
13 14.000 likes und 2000 discs ist voll
okay so aber es gibt halt auch eine
sache die die mich so aufregt und die
ist durch dieses video noch einmal mehr
heraus gestochen so auch auf mich
bezogen oder generell halt auf ganz
youtube deutschland bezogen also das
wirklich nicht nur beim awo special so
sondern auch bei ganz vielen anderen avo
session von irgendwelchen youtube das
ding ist eigentlich ganz einfach ich
mein so jeder youtuber ist in seinem
eigenen standards so jedes video geht in
die gleiche richtung jedes video wird
ungefähr gleich produziert jedes video
wird ungefähr gleich geschnitten es wird
immer die gleiche chemnitz und so weiter
das hat einfach sondern ablauf der
wiederholt sich immer und ja das ist
halt klar so für mich dieses youtube
macht mir natürlich unfassbar viel spaß
aber man will halt auch wirklich mal
andere sachen machen man muss man
irgendwann daraus aus diesem standard
herausforderungen suchen weil würde ich
immer nur diese gleichen videos machen
ich hatte jetzt schon keinen spaß mit
das könnt ihr euch sagen so wie es ist
dann braucht als youtube sowie es in
jeder anderen sportart in jedem anderen
beruf auch ist herausforderung wo man
halt noch besser werden kann muss sich
herausforderungen suchen ich will da
noch besser werden ich will das mal
ausprobieren ich will das schaffen ich
will das auch die kette bekommen und so
weiter und keine ahnung dieser
herausforderung versuche ich mir
natürlich auch zu suchen und worauf ich
hinauswill sind weg diese kommentare
wenn so leute schreiben so bohr denkt
jetzt jeder youtuber nur weil er ein
bisschen fame hat dass er musik machen
kann denkt jetzt jeder youtuber er kann
singen so trauriges youtube deutschland
so wo ich mir denke leute ganz ehrlich
haltet
und verpisst euch ihr müsst euch das
doch gar nicht angucken man das sind
dreieinhalb minuten entweder ihr guckt
euch die andere guckt euch dreieinhalb
minuten anderes video aber verpisst euch
mit diesen kommentaren es geht mir so
auf die alleine ohne scheu ich hab doch
wirklich niemals gesagt dass das musik
sein soll oder dass ich irgendwie
musikalisch begabten so das war halt so
ein track so aber das wasser auch im
endeffekt aber man muss sich auch
wirklich vorstellen so ein eigenes zu
machen das macht einfach und fast noch
viel spaß oder man halt so in diesem
projekt drin ist man muss den song
schreiben man muss den komponieren das
kann ich alles nicht deswegen habe ich
mir da suche ich mir auch immer hilft
von guten freund von mir
die das können so aber man ist selber
auch diesen projekten dann dreht man ein
geiles video guckt was passt und was
nicht und das ist einfach viel
spannender als einfach jetzt zum
beispiel dieses video zu drehen oder
keine ahnung irgendeine neuen prank zu
drehen oder sonstwas so meinem einen
standard videos sag ich mal ich hab das
ja auch schon öfter gesagt ich bin
wirklich seit meinem siebten oder achten
lebensjahr gitarre und ich war früher
mal im chor das war vielleicht jetzt
nicht so eine gute entscheidung so weiß
wirklich scheiße langweilig war aber so
gitarrespiel und so musik machen dass
das macht mir spaß und ich finde das
wirklich cool so was machen zu können
und ob ich jetzt kann oder nicht sei
dahingestellt ich weiß ganz genau dass
ich immer besser werde und ich sag mal
so in zwei jahren mal gucken was daraus
hierzu und da verstehe ich wirklich so
viele leute von euch da draußen ich
meine klar es gibt youtuber ich sag
jetzt mal keinen namen die von sich sehr
überzeugt sind und meinen sie wären der
heftigste rapper und der krasseste
schiff wird da kommen wo ist eigentlich
nur scheiße war es bei rumgekommen ist
so aber ich hab doch niemals gesagt dass
ich singen oder rappen kann ich mache
nur das was mir spaß macht und ich
versuche darin besser zu werden bei den
sachen die mir spaß macht ich meine das
ist auch wichtig wie gesagt uns hat sich
jetzt schon längst keinen spaß mehr an
youtube will sich ausprobieren man wird
besser werden und wie schon eben gesagt
mal sehen wie das in zwei jahren ausgeht
ich werde wäre damit nicht aufhören oder
sonst versucht es gibt ja auch die
meisten leute klar mit abstand den
meisten leuten die finden das cool so 13
14001 2004 es ist das schon aber diese
kommentare genau diese kommentare denkt
jetzt jeder user kann singen oder
youtube deutschland als youtube
deutschland an
ihr seid doch selber schuld daran ihr
guckt auch diese sachen armes youtube
deutschland ist ganz ehrlich das sage
ich euch jetzt so offen so das video mit
meiner freundin das hat zwei stunden
nicht mal eineinhalb stunden habe ich
daran gesessen das video hat 70 700
tausend klicks und über 40.000 likes
das ist das ist krank und ein video wo
man wirklich 30 stunden lang dran
produziert oder keine ahnung 20 stunden
lange dran produziert das hat dann
vielleicht 200.000 klicks und da denke
ich mir so diese kommentare von euch arm
ist youtube deutschland die macht keinen
sinn weil die haben dann wirklich 500
likes unter diesem video wo halt armes
youtube deutschland widergespiegelt wird
dass das ist doch total der widerspruch
das ergibt keinen sinn
ihr seid dafür schuld dass ihr dieses
video das ihr diese videos feierten das
youtuber diese videos machen diese
brains und sonst was uns so weiter klar
das macht mir auch spaß aber man kann
natürlich auch qualitativ hochwertigere
videos machen aber ein auf youtube ist
zurzeit so quantitativ muss alles passen
man muss sieben mal die woche ein video
hochladen
damit läuft und vielleicht nicht
siebenmal aber schon drei vier mal das
wollte ich einfach mal so loswerden klar
es ist nur ein ganz kleiner bruchteil
von meinen zuschauern die so denken aber
über denkt dass mal das ergibt keinen
sinn allerdings wie schon gesagt so ich
weiß auch ganz genau ich habe auch von
ganz vielen guten youtube freunden oder
kollegen die halt auch professionell
musik machen habe ich lob bekommen dass
es auf jeden fall schon mal eine
steigerung war und ich will mich
natürlich auch weiter steigern deshalb
habe ich auch jascha dazu geholt also in
meinem 200.000 abonnenten zwar kein
keiner sagen deckel sich mit musik licht
aus oder der kann ich singen weil er
kann wirklich singen so man kann einfach
nicht gleich perfekt sein ich meinen
guckt euch doch einfach mal meine ersten
youtube videos an und guckt euch die
jetzigen an vergleicht es dann mal
runter fällt euch eventuell auch in ganz
kleiner unterschied ein oder auf ein auf
auf genau auf und was ich dann auch noch
hinzufügen wollte es ist einfach ein abo
special es ist keine ernstzunehmende
musik ich will jetzt keine ernste musik
machen ich bin youtuber der nebenbei ein
bisschen musik macht es gibt auch
musiker die nebenbei youtube machen das
sagt doch auch keiner was und es ist
einfach ein freetrack des komplett frei
ihr müsst dafür kein geld bezahlen guckt
euch an oder nicht aber spart euch doch
diese kommentare armes youtube
deutschland oder sonstigen was ich
versteh's nicht so dass das verstehe ich
nicht wie man so denken kann aber gut
ich wollte nur kurz mal dieses statement
video dazu abgeben ihr könnt ihr eure
meinung dazu in die kommentare schreiben
wenn ihr genau so denkt wie ich dann
wird hier einfach mal freuen wenn ihr
daumen nach oben da las dann sehe ich
das ja vielleicht konnte jetzt auch den
einen oder anderen mal etwas vom denken
her um stimmen
ja das war's mit dem video wenn es euch
gefallen hat
hat solche gefallen wie gesagt wenn ihr
so denkt wie ich lasse meine daumen nach
oben da schreibt in die kommentare
und so weiter wir sehen uns morgen schon
wieder mit dem nächsten video check das
300.000 special noch ab würde mich sehr
freuen wenn er das noch mal einklicken
würdet und euch das anschauen würde zwar
nicht gesehen habt lippis wir sehen uns
morgen 18 uhr
haut rein